I'm the only one you can unite Democrats
and Republicans
because I seem to be opposed papa
thirty million dollars those comments
from Roy Moore just moments ago after an
eventful and chaotic day in the Alabama
Senate race the Republican National
Committee has announced it is
withdrawing support for Judge Moore's
candidacy and pulling out of a joint
fundraising agreement for the Alabama
special Senate election and this is all
in response to multiple allegations now
that Moore had made unwanted sexual
advances toward teenagers back in the
70s Senate Majority Leader Mitch
McConnell is even floating the idea of
Attorney General Jeff Sessions returning
to his old Senate seat there Alabamian
who would you know fit that standard
would be the Attorney General he's
totally well known and extremely popular
in Alabama I've spoken with the
president he called me from Vietnam
largely about this on Friday I talked to
general Kelley on Saturday at the vice
president yesterday obviously we're in
discussion here about how to salvage
this seat if possible but it's not all
bad news for judge Moore Alabama
Republican Party chairwoman Terry Lathan
has not turned on more yet and told
local media yesterday quote it would be
a serious error for any current elected
GOP official or candidate to publicly
endorse another party's candidate an
independent or a third party candidate
or a write-in candidate in a general
election as well close quote
and a new poll from Fox 10 in Alabama
shows more leads his Democratic opponent
Doug Jones by six points joining us now
for reaction in Birmingham is Alabama
Secretary of State John Merrill in New
York conservative commentator Monica
Crowley and here with me in Washington
is Katherine mango Ward who's editor in
chief of Reason magazine great to see
all of you Monica let's start with you
this has been a wild few days on this
Roy Moore situation you got the
establishment types turned on them
pretty fast but then you had Mike Lee in
Utah senator from Utah you had Ted Cruz
and now my colleague Sean Hannity says
basically you have 24 hours to clear up
the disk
references in your statements how can
Roy Moore possibly hang in under these
circumstances I'm not sure he can Laura
I mean there's certain political
realities at play here and gravity does
tend to kick in especially when the
money starts to disappear the RNC pulled
the funding as well as the field
operation that they were going to
implement to get out the vote for Roy
Moore with those two things missing
Laura I don't see how he's able to
survive it doesn't sound tonight like
he's willing to go anywhere yet but when
these realities start to kick in over
the next 24 hours when the money
disappears you know you can't run a
campaign on fumes or love that I think
is when the hard choices are going to
come in front of Roy Moore when he
doesn't have the institutional support
to continue this campaign let's go to
the Secretary of State John Merrill John
what happens if the election is held and
those absentee ballots are left over if
in fact Roy Moore steps aside the party
you know relinquishes any connection to
Roy Moore did the absentee ballots still
count in that case well Laura they do
and I think it's very important for your
viewers to note too that our people have
been voting since October the 18th
that's when the absentee ballots first
went out for consideration and for our
voters to be able to have their opinion
known and have their voice heard and
that's not just the you Aqaba military
overseas voters that's a number of
voters throughout the entire state of
Alabama I think it's important to note
that if Judge more withdrawals from the
campaign or if the state party disavows
their association with judge Moore and
determines that they no longer support
him and both of those actions have to
take place formally by them indicating
to our office that they no longer wish
to pursue the candidacy of judge Roy
Moore in the US Senate that even though
judge Moore's name will still be on the
ballot if he gets the most votes as a
plurality winner on December the 12th
then our election will be null and void
Katherine now Mitch McConnell is saying
perhaps they won't seat him or that once
he's in if he gets elected indeed gets
elected that they'll move to remove him
now if you're someone in the south and
you know even you didn't follow this
much and maybe think more and more like
Dayton 17-year olds or 18-year olds it
might come across to you as this is the
old guard telling the southerners
they're stupid bunch of Yahoo hayseed
types and they might just be like you
know something he's seated you're you
know this is just another example of the
elites kick and kick and people like us
around I think this is Congress reaping
the fact that they are wildly unpopular
Congress has like a 19 percent approval
rating that high I know it sounds almost
I don't think so and the idea that they
don't have the trust of the American
people that they are not in a position
to say hey this is an extraordinary
circumstance we want to take the high
road here we want to do an investigation
I would love to see them do an
investigation through a trusted third
party they don't have to take the
Washington Post word for it they don't
even have to believe the Apple research
if that's what they think is going on
but I do think they need to take it
seriously particularly if they want to
say listen we're better than the
Democratic Party who's constantly
apologizing for their guys when they get
accused of this kind of thing yeah well
Monica need we go back to the menendez
trial and you know we might have a
deadlock situation there now but there
was a time where there were allegations
and daily news and a lot of publications
went with them that you know allegedly
he took trips to the Dominican Republic
and had you know relationship sexual in
nature with underage hookers I don't
recall a single Democrat calling for his
resignation same thing with the old
story about Barney Frank all those years
ago and many others so you know the
Democrats seem to cover cover for their
own but I guess the Republicans they
want to come across looking a lot better
than that
well Democrats have always circled the
wagons and protected their candidates
and protected their presidents and
protected their their their own for a
really long time and Republicans always
went into a circular firing squad Laura
but I think what makes these cases so
different right now is that we are in a
completely different cultural moment
with all of these stories of sexual
harassment coming out of Hollywood and
the media elite the modeling world
music world and so on that given this
moment these folks cannot survive it and
even folks at the high end in the
leadership of both parties and both
establishments etc are now no longer
saying that this is acceptable and and
are less willing Laura to cover for
these folks and you're seeing it now
happening on both sides and that's why I
think in the Roy Moore situation in many
ways he is going to be a casualty of
this moment and where as may perhaps he
may have survived look Donald Trump in
the tail end of the campaign with the
Access Hollywood tape he was able to
sort of harness a boomerang effect where
people felt that that was a pylon and
they came out and rallied around him but
Donald Trump was an exceptional figure
and I'm not so sure that it's gonna be
able to do it that's right more is not
Donald Trump Secretary of State I just
want to just close out with you and you
in your estimation right now I know
you're still kind of standing behind Roy
Moore does he stay in this race and does
he get elected well I think it would be
highly unusual for judge Moore to step
aside that would be against every type
of so that's an example that he has said
I don't see him getting out of the race
party of well I'll tell you it's it's
going to be extremely extremely close
law and I hear mixed reviews all around
the state of Alabama this is a very
disconcerting time for our state and now
this is not the way we like to be
featured in the national limelight I
can't no I can't imagine thanks for
joining us John